all right so I've got good news for you
it is pool season and you don't need
your pool body because we're talking
cocktails at the Boulevard pool at the
Cosmopolitan so joining us right now
we've got here in the studio mixologist
Andrew Pollard Chef Steve gothamer here
both from the cosmo thanks for coming in
guys looking forward to pool season the
cosmos always dialed it all the way to
11. let's start with some booze what do
you think in happy hour too absolutely
happy hour so you can't drink all day if
you don't start early so here we are
bright and early yeah that's fantastic
these babies are fully loaded Full Steam
what have you already made for us here
so uh what we have Sierra just to
celebrate our Sunset cocktail hours of
the most prestige happy hours in Las
Vegas with an unparalleled view of the
entire Las Vegas Boulevard
um it's very instagramable it's very
instagramable Everything is Everything
check out mine I've got some pictures up
there yes that's this guy look at that
smile that's an Instagram smile thank
you so we have here is actually we have
a few of our favorite uh classic
Daiquiris a drink that is so simple
dating back to 19th century Cuba just
simply rum lime and sugar fresh bacon
usually we think of this very frivolous
sweet Frozen not too sweet not too sweet
fresh everything here is fresh so we've
got a fresh classic Daiquiri we have the
Vivian Ward which is a variation of our
of a strawberry daiquirer if we know the
movie Pretty Woman of course
[Applause]
that bathtub with roses
is that festive and then a very kind of
a honeymoon and a glass here with our
with our love birds here Griff and Ruby
for a kind of a tropical exotic
variation and you can be manly like John
langler and drink one of these fruity
cocktails this would look really good on
it
they're delicious they pack a punch so
let me tell you folks they pack a punch
all right and Chef you've got some great
great food items too that that folks can
have this the cocktail hour by the way
is between 6 30 and 8 30 on Friday we do
and with all these great cocktails we
have to try to have some small bites to
balance it out it's hard to compete with
Andrew's awesome beverages but we try
but we have some shrimp toast we have
our Korean fried cauliflower that we
also offer at the Overlook Grill it's a
really great something different you
don't normally see it happy hour type
things but vegan gluten-free so awesome
choices our signature guacamole and
obviously the standards that everybody
loves like our uh Smash Burgers oh you
know pool season is always such a big
deal in Las Vegas and everybody does
them of course in their own unique way
how do you how challenging is it to
stand out and to try and get customers
in and to to make them entertain and
want to go to the cosmo when it's so
darn hot outside well we're obviously
great refreshing cocktails fun food it's
festive it's different it's Unique we
always look at kind of where we are and
where it can improve which isn't always
but were we not and what are things that
are more Innovative and new and
different and nobody's nobody in Las
Vegas is doing fresh egg and Daiquiris
on a Friday during Happy Hour Friday
happy hour sells it for me and then we
have to remind folks because MGM is is
operating the property now it's three
free hours of parking for locals here we
go that's a huge deal plenty of time to
get into trouble yeah two hours three
hours of free parking gives you a little
time there Andrew and Steve thanks for
coming in from the cosmo talking about
the the happy hour all the pool season
stuff happening at the Cosmopolitan we
really appreciate the time guys thank
you appreciate it really quick dive in
movies and they're doing some yoga on
the pool I know we're running out of
time so I just wanted to mention it
we're going to put website you guys yes
give me one of these there you go come
on all right cheers